I'm bored  me too let's do something I know  let's drink soda and hit each other okay  wait a minute kids you don't want to do  that sodas are bad for you and being hit  can hurt why not do it in a video game  instead Double Dragon neon has all the  soda drinking bad guy punching  high-fiving mixtape jamming coolness  that you'll ever need and it's way  healthier for you than getting beat up  or drinking sodas just ask this  scientist hi I'm not really a scientist  but I found this lab code this chart  here says that getting hit hurts  and our newest science Double Dragon  neon is the future of fusion where  everything is totally radical to the max  and no one ever gets heat up and robots  fool us all and the brand-new online  co-op mode is totally Cowabunga Double  Dragon neon is coming soon to steam  awesome  [Music]  you